for me I'm only interested in one thing
I'm only interested in the thing that is
binding us all together no matter what
you do in this room no matter what your
profession is an entrepreneur work for
an agency designer developer no matter
what you do always and forever our job
is to tell our story and that is never
going to change the way you make real
money the way you make real impact the
way things get changed is by great
storytelling it's always been that way
and it always will be that way because I
don't know if you guys heard but we're
[ __ ] human beings and that's what we
like right and this is important it's
important for you to think about what I
just said there because really we need
to reverse engineer what's actually
happening and that's what I spend my
time doing not knowing how many of you
know me my whole career is predicated on
reverse engineering what I think is
going to happen in the next 24 months
because that was still practical right
yes I know we're all going to be robots
eventually but that's 40 60 80 years out
I'm worried about 24 months out and my
biggest problem right now in general is
that I feel that the far majority of
people businesses organizations media
companies all across the board are
storytelling like it's 2007 in a 2014
world and that's all I ever think about
see what I spend a lot of my time now
and doing is figuring out how to story
tell in micro moments that we live in
the greatest a DD culture of our time
that we have absolutely no time I'm
obsessed with the notion of how do I
tell you my story when you take out your
phone and you do this right that's what
we now do we don't sit on a couch where
we don't have a remote control like it
was 1982 right and we were able to tell
that story because the audience was
captive right we were too lazy to get up
and unless you're going to make popcorn
or take a piss
you're gonna see our story right now we
live in a world where we have
obnoxious amounts unlimited amounts of
outlets to do what we want to do on our
time and how we want to do it we live in
a world where people only want to watch
TV now where they watch the entire
season in one night right that's I mean
that like that's how we roll it to on
our time how many people here I'm this
is gonna be a lot of fun for me I'm
gonna block the light how many people
here by show hands and don't have ask me
your head nod me give me your full
[ __ ] hand how many people here get
pissed when somebody calls them raise
your hand let me just tell you something
right now thank you for the lights keep
that on because I like the faces 70% of
this audience just raised their hand at
the thought that if another human being
calls them they're pissed and annoyed
you know why because we've gotten to a
place where everything now is on our
time right you watch the show when you
want to watch not because it airs on
Wednesday from 8:00 to 9:00 p.m. right
you like texting because you can respond
to that person on your time we're in
control of the one asset that we all
give the most [ __ ] about and that's time
and with that that has created an
awfully interesting challenge to
actually storytelling the reality we're
living in the world heard we heard a few
minutes ago that campaigns are
everything
no campaigns aren't everything right and
it was funny I actually think they're
both right I don't think a lot changed
when you really think about it I just
think that what social networks have
done and mobile devices have done is
they've created a gateway drug to
awareness that's how I look at it you
know how I look at Instagram and
snapchat and vine and Facebook and
Twitter I look at them like they're read
right you give somebody a little nickel
bag and then later you can sell metonic
coke right so
so that's how I look at it right how do
I story tell on social and give you
something that you can consume very
lightweight and quick oh by the way the
way that we all actually roll the way we
actually consume information now which
is in hyper speed and this takes a
totally different art when I think about
the creatives that I work with you know
vaynermedia the agency I run we've gone
from 20 to 280 people in the last 18
months right and a lot of them are very
qualify in the first 30 I made sure
nobody ever worked at an agency right I
wanted have that DNA but now we're
obviously hiring extremely talented
creatives and things of that nature and
I'm trying to break them down to be
honest with you because what we're
living through is a very big cultural
shift in storytelling see we've just
lived through the last 70 years as I'd
like to call it movies and Docs right
heavy thinking a lot of prep work a lot
of things heavy thick heavy now we're
living in breaking news right the skill
set to be a great breaking news
storyteller versus being a great movie
storyteller is quite different and not
that the movie thing is dead I actually
don't think in a social media world that
stuff doesn't work I actually think it
works just fine I just don't think it
works as the only thing we can do now
and so we have this other Avenue where
we have to start respecting the nuances
of the platform I have 200 people who
spend their entire day's lives thinking
about how to actually market and story
tell where our eyeballs and ears
actually are because they're not in the
places where a lot of companies and
entrepreneurs spend their time listen
I'm not going to pick on outdoor media
print radio television that's just too
easy I'm gonna pick on digital let's
talk about Google AdWords down 15% in
the last year in click-throughs reported
by Google down digital email marketing I
built my first business my wine business
on email marketing how many people hear
of email marketed in their careers ever
just raise your hands just right great
let me let me let me blow your [ __ ]
face off you don't like do you know what
my open rate for Wine Library comm was
in 1996 with a 400,000 person email list
89 percent right you know what happened
to email marketing the one thing that I
know more than the Sun is coming up
tomorrow that marketers ruin everything
as a proud marketer it's what we do when
something new comes out we try to figure
it out go look back at 1995 to 2000
click-throughs on banner ads 10% 20% 30%
now if you get point zero one you're a
hero
marketers ruined it right email
marketing really collapse in a five in
the last three four years why oh I don't
know maybe because Groupon and
LivingSocial let's talk about them for a
half a second how many people here by
show of hands signed up for Groupon
LivingSocial or daily candy raise your
hands okay good love this crowd
everybody do you guys take go back with
me for a second do you remember four
years ago how you couldn't wait to get
$40 a [ __ ] sushi for 20 bucks that it
was the best thing that ever happened to
you that you couldn't wait to get that
$80 spa treatment for $40 but what
happened you hate it now you know why
you all unsubscribed and deleted because
they started giving you more stuff that
you didn't want
now you don't give a [ __ ] if they're
offering you a million dollar house for
a hundred bucks you're like delete spam
unsubscribe
and the same things happening in social
inevitably but then you start looking at
why Facebook in my opinion Facebook's
the worst PR company and the Facebook
should fire everybody in the PR
department because they are positioning
themselves so poorly when they're
actually executing on the future of
storytelling now they're getting a
little rogue because they're getting
excited bout their stock price and
pushing a little too much to the paid
but the fact of the matter is the notion
of we are not great at self policing the
content we see and we don't unsubscribe
you're still following people on
Facebook that dating your best friend
four years ago it's just what we do we
don't want to subscribe right and so the
notion of letting the best quality
content get to you based on your actions
is going to happen whether the EdgeRank
algorithms right whether Pinterest or
tumblr or somebody out of Twitter
clearly needs it comes out with their
own and it's better that's up to the
science nerds
I'll let the mathematicians take care of
that horseshit what I want us to focus
on is this which is one thing quality
storytelling always wins always and what
we need to do is one major thing and
this is where everybody gets [ __ ] up
everybody thinks it's about the content
and all the action right now is in the
context let me explain everybody looks
at social networks that's probably the
smartest thing I'm going to say so maybe
if you're gonna pay attention just
listen to this one statement
everybody ninety-nine percent of the
people out there and I spent all my time
looking at all this stuff are looking at
social networks as distribution you're
doing something somewhere else and then
you're using the tweet to drive towards
it you're using the Facebook status
update to drive towards it we default
into thinking that social networks are
distribution because we treat it like
email to really win in the world that
we're all about to embark into we need
to start respecting all these platforms
and when I say social networks I'm just
using that as a general term - any
websites where people actually spend
time write anything and even better if
we actually have an ability to create a
profile on it and be part of the
conversation right and so we have to
start respecting the context and the
nuances of the room when you start
looking at the data which gets a little
math nerd even though I desktop it I
spend plenty of time on when you start
looking at if you have the exact same
thousand people on Facebook the exact
same thousand people on Pinterest
right you post the same exact thing at
the same exact time and they act
completely different that's when you
start understanding how much the context
matters because the one thing we are not
doing anywhere close to enough in our
space a smart people that are in this
awesome room the one thing we are not
doing enough of is respecting the
psychology of why people are in where
they are at that time this isn't social
network sites this is Facebook
this is Pinterest this is Instagram this
is vine tumblr on there very very very
different when you are on Facebook
that's an all-encompassing awareness
around your social graph when you're on
Pinterest your psychology is intent to
buy or aspiration to buy you need to be
story telling differently in those
platforms we have to be giving them
different visuals that are mapped to the
psychology not to the number of users
that are there not to why we need to be
why they're there now how come they're
there and we have to really start
focusing on this because when you start
looking at it the one thing that is
really deteriorating in our world is the
amount of time we have everybody's
pounding at this one asset it's the one
asset that none of us are going to get
more of and the battle the supply and
demand of attention is completely out of
control completely listen if any of you
grew up in Jersey or drive through
Jersey you know that I love outdoor
media building up Wine Library TV I put
up billboards of myself mainly because I
have that commute from New York and I
just like looking at myself I've got an
ego like that but I love outdoor media
it brand this that the other thing I've
stopped being excited about outdoor
media because I was looking around and
I've got something for you guys to all
do I know probably a lot of you live in
a city but the next time you're out of
it or you're driving do me one favor
remember this talk and when you're
driving look at five people and I
promise you three of them are texting
right
Oprah's right it's dangerous out there
it's getting real dangerous out there
right so my friends outdoor media my
clients are spending hundreds of
millions of dollars trying to tell
stories on billboards
meanwhile customers aren't looking at
billboards they're not even looking at
the [ __ ] road anymore
and this doesn't take an account to the
fact that we have self-driving cars
coming you think you can be looking at
billboard you can be [ __ ] working
we're gonna be [ __ ] eating and
talking and [ __ ] chilling I don't
know you know and so we're living
through a major culture shift and the
only thing anybody in this room should
care about that is the same for
everybody is where the eyes and ears of
everybody are that's what matters
attention is the only commodity it's the
only asset excuse me that we need to be
paying attention to and our customers
and we know this because everybody here
is living it we're doing different
things we're looking at more mobile
devices where we're playing cops and
robbers with advertising go look at the
normal person that uses YouTube a lot
when they open up YouTube videos they
open up 14 tabs to let the ad run and
then they go back and actually watch it
and so like we have to get out of this
stupid thought of awareness and we have
to start getting too emotional attention
are we actually bringing them value do
we actually talk to them about what they
want in these spheres it's not about
pushing advertising it's about bringing
value in the sphere why does somebody
like to go to tumblr because they like
[ __ ] animated gifs so give it to them
right and give it to them in a way that
a human being would give it to them not
a brand and be smart about it and then
in general you know on this thesis from
a business standpoint I'm writing a new
book it's called Jab Jab Jab right hook
right and the notion is give give give
ask give give give to ask the real funny
thing to me in the world right now is
that everybody's full of [ __ ] right and
what I mean by that is when you look at
people tweeting or facebooking they're
trying to disguise their ask by being
witty right meanwhile the one thing I
know more than anything is that our
collective [ __ ] radars today
compared to 15 years ago are
dramatically better and the kids [ __ ]
their [ __ ] radars are excelling they
just think that they just know it right
so what I've been testing a lot of and
believe a lot of value in is jab jab jab
right hook give people value and funny
stories give them an animated gif that
just makes them laugh right that just
makes say happy Monday it's fine you
don't need a business objective for
every piece of creative because we live
in a world now where it's not just about
campaign
where he do two or three when you spend
all your money you live in a world where
we're doing it every day a lot of it and
so we have the freedom the creative
freedom to actually act human and bring
a little value to that bring value bring
value bring value respond engage bring
value make it funny make it newsworthy
and then let's all become grownups once
and for all and recognize we can ask for
the business if we're just off entick
about it a funny thing happens when you
give a fuckload of value up front you
guilt people into buying [ __ ] and so we
give value give value act human do the
right thing answer be there for them
have good everybody on like Twitter
everybody that you have to be funny on
Twitter like funny is like the one
characteristic that works up everything
works on Twitter it's a human platform
and the problem is most people don't
want to be self-deprecating or or have
empathy or be kind like it's there's not
that many and nobody wants to put it out
there they think they want to put out
something that gets retweeted how about
we listen instead of talk people like
that
think about the friend that you would
rather call instead of the friend that
always calls you and then think about
who you want to hang out with right and
so we have to act human we have to bring
value and then you say value value value
and then you say buy my [ __ ] book
right and that's kind of the science you
know boxing is known as a sweet science
that's why I use this metaphor for title
it's how I think I'm spending all my
time and energy and I highly recommend
whatever energy you're spending on this
you spend more because the attention the
eyes the ears of our consumers they're
clearly going in these places they're
clearly going in these places and if we
do not figure out the art and the
science of how to actually storytelling
them not use them as just distribution
realize how stupid is is to use the same
picture on Instagram Facebook Twitter
and Tumblr realize that understand
there's a real science in this a real
storytelling battle going on right now
in these platforms and understanding
that you as an individual act
differently when you go into a boardroom
in a business meeting than you would
when you go with your girls to Las Vegas
for the weekend then when you would when
you go out with your boyfriend you're
still the same person but the context of
the room changes the way you story tell
thank you